September is coming to a close but
before it goes it's gifting us with
games before the busy month of October
we're starting off this week in the
outback for forza horizon 3 set in the
open world based on Australia and what
an open world it is this map is twice as
big as forza horizon 2 taking us from
Surfers Paradise to Byron Bay don't know
your australian geography well it's a
lot of road and you get to cover it with
three other friends in the four-person
cooperative multiplayer campaign you
might remember being a racer from the
ports of horizon festival that's in the
previous games but in this game you've
been promoted to director so you get to
make custom tracks and hiring fire
racers at your will at so much power
games box miguel concepts yan gave this
game a 9 out of 10 so if you're into
this series you're gonna want to give
this one a go and you're off to the
races on the twenty-seventh also this
week we're getting more soccer with FIFA
17 array soccer you're getting new
attacking techniques physical player
overhaul active intelligence system and
set piece rewrite there's an all new
single-player story campaign titled the
journey you're Alex hunter a young
footballer a real go-getter trying to
make his mark in the Premier League it's
a story that'll make Rudy look like a
lazy piece of crap player will be able
to select one of 20 Premier League clubs
to play for at the beginning of the
season you can then play any position
including goalkeeper but sadly not
waterboy the story mode will also
feature a dialogue wheel similar to Mass
Effect however none of them result in
steamy sex sequences put the ball in the
goal on the 27th
if you love XCOM but we're waiting for
console your wait is over my friend
we're getting the delightful sequel to
enemy Unknown on ps4 and Xbox one but in
case you didn't play the original you're
a military organization trying to fight
off an alien invasion but you lost the
war now you're a resistance force
against their occupation of Earth you
give commands to squad members you've
lovingly named after friends and family
members and then you nail bitingly watch
is there 98% likely shot misses and puts
them in grave danger however if you can
get critically wounded back on your ship
you can save them if they die you can
still drag their lifeless corpse onto
the ship and loot their body for weapons
and loot so it's not a full loss defend
the earth on the 27th if you're looking
for something a bit more unique this
week i would suggest burly men at sea a
folk tale about three large bearded
fishermen who go on an adventure i know
you're wondering and yes you will go out
to sea and you'll follow them every step
of the way in these clean pastel colored
sets that helps set the tone for this
whimsical and light-hearted story you
get to grow your beard on the 29th
finally darkest dungeon battles its way
to the ps4 and Vita this week so you can
pull your hair out to unbelievably
difficult scenarios where a healer is
too scared to heal and your damage
dealer doesn't listen to you and your
tank keeps hiding in the back and
nothing works and they're all dead
anyway this game is upsetting and it
will frustrate the hell out of you I
played it on pc but i bet it's just as
frustrating on everything else so if
you're in the mood for something like
this I would suggest picking it up and
that's all I have for you this week do
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and sometimes they
change I'll see you guys again next week